can you're a pretty cool guy yeah you
got tattoos
I got tattoos - that means you're cool
so cool bro are you wearing a shirt so
you can show off your tattoos I mean I
have a shirt on yeah but my tattoo you
can still see him don't you take it off
for you baby I'll strip wait I have an
idea
oh let's look at bad tattoos don't you
point at me how do you know oh you can
see me let's review some bad tattoos yay
my favorite I love making fun of other
people's life choices literally my
favorite thing to do is because you have
some insecurities about your own number
one number one some guy tried to copy my
tattoos artists work and tattooed a
nipple on his arm text Wow give me this
tattoo right here
say no more fam nipple he actually went
back to touch he wears me like dude
where's the frickin nipple yeah got the
nipple you do boy but it's not even a
bad job that's actually kind of a decent
copy job you know you think that's a
decent cut job colored it's okay you
want me to do your next tattoo bro if
you think that's decent let me let me do
your next at 10 next exhale roses are
red my name's Dave this poem makes no
sense
microwave Oh goddamn it
yeah sick roms tasting that bad he's a
wedding having this guy in front of you
at the airplane if you imagine like who
was is like wife or his girlfriend that
somehow he has having this tattoo cuts
his hair in this way yes someone has to
do it yeah it someone has to keep that
up that's like what inside it haircut
cold when you have really long in the
back like a mole or a mullet
yeah mullet America second X America's
haircut this is the level above that
of the mall so if you're on a plane you
know you just just hopped in coach
you're sit behind this guy what do you
do you know he leans this chair back
it's like he's lunging at you I could
jump scared I mean it looks like he's
flirting with me out he's a girl you
start making out I learned that my
friends Chinese tattooed literally means
turkey sandwich
what do ii i love turkey sandwiches yeah
what the hell that's what he wanted why
are you judging this i mean every
tattoos got a story right like dude what
is your tattoo mean he's just like gross
doctors like hey I could get that
Garrett I can get that off fray yeah
$120 yeah or I can get a tattoo but some
Jordan on there dug it to my ear Oh
Allison you're in the Perino yes you
know honestly this tattoo eat as small
as it is probably hurt a lot
yeah those dots on your nip so you know
like you your nipple like it's not
always hard you know I wonder what it
looks like when it kind of relaxes a
little bit right now yeah it is
ya know I mean me I got me got me fat I
don't know your nips always hard 100%
based they move around a little bit not
open your body wait wait this is our
discussion to have please keep going
have you ever have you ever just like
licked your finger they might touch the
nip and just kind of it's smaller you
know that's the tattoo also does the
space get smaller bra what are the
turtle Vinny why they call it didn't
last
it's just it's limited ads it's still
monetized because limited ads gives you
nothing and you still get something
though there's still an to play no
that's like that's like they take 90% of
your earnings and it's like hey look you
still get something
you here you go ray
yeah crashing my frickin thumbnail
speaking of bad ads Ken are you thinking
about buying a property why yes I am
consider buying a property oh wow are
you thinking about getting a mortgage to
buy a property uh yeah yeah my channel
slowly dying so I think I will have to
take one out maybe you should go to the
bank get a mortgage and buy a property
if we talk about expensive things we
will get better ads oh yes I have
thirteen Dodge Chargers and now you're
gonna buy 13 and I love tick tock videos
videos good ads is that still thing it
didn't like tik-tok least I put ads and
everything you can get a ton of money
yeah I don't know that why everybody
made kick top videos for so long
dude I resent that I make it because
they're really funny and fun to watch oh
and definitely like dodging all the
music claims is not a pain in the ass
yeah they're definitely oh that that's
not why I stopped it's my life
Jon bovi my my favorite my favorite
musician it Oh Jon bovi what is his name
Bon Jovi well the other part is it it's
is my life oh god I didn't see it yeah
[Music]
oh my lord almighty God
what on earth is that there's a Peter in
his nose oh good get sure there's mr.
Peters here take it away
Faraday's Barrett is the ultimate and my
favorite oh yes
look my head looks like a I have a
baby's body tattooed on my chest I get
all the ladies ah
it's supposed to be a galaxy this
shibori and this is your brain on crack
expect my face oh no that's if it is
real it's pretty freakin good spray I'm
pressing yeah that looks legit some Ohio
hands agrees yeah heck yeah oh nice
stars cool so you got a bunch of dots on
you some hair on her chest I'm saying
someone sprinkle pepper on you know
sometimes you gotta add a little spice
today
there we go god this stuff makes me
uncomfortable you are if you have
titties
don't ruin them why would you do that
it's kind of good it's really good look
at look at shading on that face it looks
just like Eminem on them Eminem I just
spit some rhymes on you oh my god I want
to lie and that looks like it's
screaming in pain I love Italy so much
please give me this okay here you go
say no more that's a Shrek ear what the
dots on his answer you got a unibrow
vapor dark Wow look at the vape and it
goes up into a wolf
dude is like dude Streep
it's the flavor of freedom oh crap
hello y'all call out to all you tattoo
fans I'm doing some awesome new tat
charging on the pay what you can basis
if you want to be awesome in a hero look
no further the tad above is a spiral my
own design wow I can't wait for all them
calls I'm about to get here's my
infected spiral that I did oh my it's a
little red first it's a small tattoo
it's looks like very swollen and the
line isn't even clean like it's not
supposed to expand or leak like that
yeah that's pretty good
I also asked focuses on someone's
shoulder or something but the size of
those hairs is this somebody's foot this
is a super small like a little bitty
tattoo on the side oh my god it couldn't
be you're right
oh my god this is like the 40 year old
smoking lady yeah I wouldn't get a
Playboy bunny right my hair but it's
always been a dream of mine let me go
down to the trailer park and get Oh
Frank he's kind of good in the other day
he hooked me up and they gotta pay pay
what you can prize oh yeah you did a
mean foot tattoo the other day I'm
diggin it was a spiral hot this one
didn't even get infected
oh is that donna mater it is that Kyle
oh I can't tell you so small that it's
one good joke I'm gonna buy it to to gun
to make it that way that that dog it's
easiest see you do it all the time my
dead mother this is actually she looks
like she dig her up right now I got it
so I wouldn't forget her but now I want
to at least I got the gap in her teeth
right you know oh those bras oh nice
right by the fuse box Wow go easy
oh I've seen this one it's pretty good
oh yeah yeah this is a pretty good
cover-up thick Jimmy
I got this super bad Pikachu tattoo now
here's a drunk Pikachu draw on it see
this is why you should go to a good
tattoo artists and spend that extra
dollar like I can get that $20.00 tattoo
or spend 120 dollars per hour you know
it's something that I'm not going to
regret tattoos are awesome and you
should get one yeah yeah yeah yeah and
if anyone says there goes bad when
you're old
who cares you're gonna be old and
looking bad anyway that's right yeah
just don't get it on your face or your
hands because then you'll be
unemployable check out ken everyone what
you never played super simulator you
know it's fun right I'm not supposed to
give my opinion but give it a try and
then you can tell me if it's good or not
convinced yet okay I'll cut you a deal
the game is available for free and
that's a great price
[Music]